(audience cheer and applaud)
- [Kelly] Okay, I had my-
- Wow!
- I had my teeth made 'cause
I couldn't sing with them,
so here we go, okay okay.
- Is this Invisalign?
What's happening?
- I literally, it is like
a little, but I was like,
I can't sing a song like this.
- [Kyle] No, you're fully
committed right now.
- Yeah, I'm committed.
I don't know if I'll have to take them out
for this interview
because I'm eating the teeth
right now, but it's fine.
- (lisping) Do you want
me to talk like this too
so it's even and fair?
- Yeah, just make me
feel good about myself.
Do you love Halloween? Do you
dress up? Do you get into it?
- I love Halloween.
- [Kelly] Me too.
- I have a real connection with Halloween.
- [Kelly] Oh yeah.
- You know, my co-star
when I was a little girl,
when I was five years old, Michael Landon,
his birthday was Halloween.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I always loved him so much.
And then I did some
horror films, you know,
- [Kelly] A few, yeah.
- Yes, and then also my daughter,
my eldest daughter Farrah
is born on Halloween.
- I didn't know that, that's cool.
- Yeah, so we love to like decorate.
As soon as Halloween, October hits,
my whole house is
decorated, inside and out,
because to me it's like the
kick off of all the holidays.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Kyle] And it's like
Thanksgiving, Christmas.
- [Kelly] That is true,
it's the kickoff, yeah.
Oh, I love the decorations.
- [Kyle] Thank you.
That's my dining table at home right now.
- Okay, so I do wanna come back to you,
Farrah, who was born on Halloween.
You went, so you're like having Halloween,
like carving pumpkins
and you go into labor?
- Yes, I was 19 years old,
I was carving a pumpkin and I was pregnant
and went into labor.
and she was born at 8:13 on Halloween.
- I mean, it's kind of incredible
'cause your family's
probably all together anyway.
- Oh, my family, we have all,
my sisters, Kathy, Kim and I,
we've all, when we've given birth,
we've all been in the hospital
rooms with each other.
- Oh wow.
- And her husband Rick
videotaped all our births.
I know that sounds
really weird, but he did.
(audience laugh)
And yeah, so when I looked up,
I had my sisters for moral support,
I was a young Mom, I was terrified.
- Yeah.
- And I had friends there,
my Mom was at the Polo
Lounge in Beverly Hills
and brought like half
the polo lounge with her.
And I looked up and at one
point there was 19 people
in the room when I gave birth.
- That's a little...
- It's a little much.
- It's a little much,
I mean, for you, I just mean
that would be overwhelming.
- My sister Kathy took the baby first
and then she looked at my then husband
and said, would you like to hold the baby?
So generous, you know?
- Oh my God, no,
so here's the thing
about, did you do this?
Like, I was so terrified.
I don't know why, but I was so terrified,
especially with my first kid,
that somebody was gonna take my baby.
So I looked at my sister,
like grabbed her and my ex
and I was like, if you
lose sight of my daughter,
I will never love you again.
- I had that same thing.
- I need you to follow wherever she goes.
And like, I was like so nervous about it.
- Because you hear those stories.
- [Kelly] I know!
- I also have that fear.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
Yes.
- It's a little irrational,
but I don't care.
So, wait, so do you believe
in like, supernatural stuff?
Have you ever seen ghosts
or, I haven't and I want to.
- Oh, come over to my house.
Yes, I have.
- I don't know if
they'd show themselves to me,
- Thank God they haven't
actually shown themselves
'cause I don't know, I
wouldn't be here right now.
- I would want to see it.
(audience laugh)
- You think that, you think that?
- No, I 100% think it would be cool.
- Okay, well I've had some things happen.
I've lost both my parents and
I've had some things happen.
- Okay.
- Like a lot of things happen,
especially after my mom passed away,
or very strange things
happen, like lights going on
where they weren't even plugged in,
really weird things.
- Yeah.
- So I have no doubt I believe in that.
And then my house that I live
in now was built in like 1882
and moved by like trolley in 1912.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I hear footsteps a lot,
everyone in my family
has heard the footsteps.
- Yeah.
- And Smokey Robinson
actually used to own my home,
and I was at an Oscar
party this past Oscars.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- And he said, oh, have you
heard the footsteps yet?
I did not need to hear that.
(audience laugh)
(Kelly gasps)
- I was like, I wanted to
believe that I was imagining it,
but the funny thing is
that it feels safe though.
It's like a good experience.
- Yeah, I don't feel
unsafe around it, yeah.
- Yeah but we've seen the movies,
we don't know what's gonna happen.
- Those are movies though.
I really wanna see one Kyle, okay.
(audience applaud)
Looks like a not a fun dinner party.
It seemed like it didn't go well.
- So I don't have a lot of luck
with dinner parties apparently.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- So yeah, we had a dinner
party season one called,
we referred to it as the
dinner party from Hell.
- Yeah.
- This is supposedly on
par, if not worse than that.
- [Kelly] Oh no.
- Yeah, that was actually a crazy night,
everybody lost their marbles.
And we had like, current
housewives and past housewives.
We had Camille Grammar there.
Denise Richards, Faye Resnick was there,
we had the entire cast
and it just had the makings
of just a complete disaster.
- You know, the producers were like, yeah.
- Yeah, I mean I of
course, there was tears,
there was screaming and you know,
of course they're like, are you okay?
Oh and you'll be fine, right?
I'm like, yeah, they do love that.
- I have to say though,
I've gone through public
separation and divorce.
That is the worst thing ever.
We were talking about in commercial break,
how do you, I feel like I
was on TV the whole time too,
but in a different way.
Like, y'all shoot reality
so they got everything
kind of behind the scenes.
- They did.
And it was like, you
know, it's really hard
because, we're going through,
we are separated, it's amicable,
but it's still really difficult.
And I wasn't quite ready
to share in the beginning.
And it was, it's just
painful no matter what.
- Yeah.
- This is not what my
fairytale was supposed to be.
- [Kelly] Girl.
- So it is really hard.
And everybody's weighing in
and people all of a sudden
like, you crushed our dreams.
You know, we don't believe in true love.
I'm like, no, we really.
We had an amazing love story
- You're like, what do you
think I think about true love
- [Kyle] for a very long time.
- right now?
- [Kyle] Yeah, exactly!
- Like where do you think
I'm at on the spectrum.
- I'm gonna worry about my family,
now I've gotta worry about
a few million people too,
what what they think.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And it makes it a lot more difficult.
- Yeah.
I do think though, being able to be
that vulnerable in that situation
is probably gonna help a lot of people
just relate to it and
feel not alone in it.
'cause that's the worst.
That grief and loss, even
if it's something you want,
it's something that went terribly wrong
that you did not see coming, you know?
- [Kyle] Yeah.
- And that's hard.
- And everybody wants to put
their spin on what they think it is.
- Yeah, when they really,
usually don't know it all.
- And they know so much about your life.
- Yeah.
- And they think that we deserve to know
everything that's going on,
like, what caused this, what happened?
And then if you don't tell them,
they come up with their own idea.
So it's just, you know.
- Which is super fun.
(she laughs)
- It's so much fun, it's so much fun.
I love reading lies about myself everyday.
- Yeah, it is so fun.
And my Mom calls me and my Mom,
I'm like, people lie,
I'm like, Mom, it's a lie.
It's not like real, like, what's in there,
and she's like,
I don't know well people
are gonna believe this.
And I'm like, just let it go, Elsa.
- It's so hard, I know!
- But you, I have to ask this too.
So y'all, you went to a psychic,
y'all did a psychic reading
and people are saying that
they predicted this separation.
- Well yes, season one.
She said that your husband does
not emotionally fulfill you.
She said to me.
But funniest thing is
that now everyone's like,
oh, she was right, she predicted this.
But she also said, oh,
it's your second marriage,
oh, then you're fine,
you won't get divorced.
I really do feel like
she was picking up on
Camille Grammar because
she was hiding their issues
and Kelsey did end up leaving, you know,
and they were going
through their thing so,
I stand by that because
we really were very happy
for a very long time, very long time.
- Yeah, very long time, years.
- I still consider us a success story, so.
- Yeah.
You know, what's so funny.
So after all of it, I say
that to him, I'm like,
you know, I'm not gonna
poo poo on the whole thing.
Like, there were really great parts
and even if it was one
sided in certain areas,
like it still was real for me.
And it was beautiful for me.
And I think that's wonderful,
'cause not everybody feels in life,
not everybody gets a chance.
(audience cheer and applaud)
And I think that's beautiful
to be able to feel that.
And you know it exists, you know?
Okay, so do you ever have plans to retire?
'Cause 13 years,
I feel like I'm looking at like
Blake Shelton on the Voice.
Like, it's like, you know what I'm saying?
Like that's hard.
I was looking at him, I was like,
this is gonna be hard for you man.
This is like a life for you.
- I'm thinking about
what Portia said to me
when she was little right now.
- Yeah, you're not dead, you can't quit.
- You know, I don't see myself
ever quitting, you know,
acting and things like that.
That's my first love, but of
course there's times I think,
this has to come to an end at some point.
It's not necessarily, aligned
with who I am at times,
because it can be very
difficult and challenging
and provokes me my anxiety.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But it's hard because
it's really woven into,
my life for so many years.
It would be very painful
even to walk away from
just the crew and production and all that,
because I love those people so much.
- Yeah, I do understand that.
I think people don't realize that
when they're watching at home,
how invested you get with people.
- People become your family.
- Yeah.
- It's very hard.
- You see them more than your family.
- Exactly.
So one day it'll come though.
That day will come.
- Alright, alright, well
we need another break.
But you can see the Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills
Wednesdays on Bravo and streaming
the next day on Peacock.